now here we have the
uh i believe it's the battle of the
trident
it's robert baratheon uh who is the king
who
at the beginning of game of thrones and
he's
fighting prince rhaegar targaryen
who is uh daenerys brother
and he's also the heir to the throne of
the mad king aries
um who was shortly after this killed by
jamie lannister
i got that right that's right okay
um this is one of the key uh the key
scenes in a song of ice and fire that
occurs you know before the books open
but it sets the stage and everything
that follows uh
let's see this is uh justin sweet right
the painting
yes yes justin ma incredible artist
justin sweet he's done some magnificent
uh work for us
um we've had um
several great artists do the battle of
the trident scene
um what i like about justin's version
particularly is that he
he actually included the horse the
horses um
because they the two of them did fight
on horseback but most of the other
artists who have
uh illustrated the scene for one reason
another have omitted the horses
and have just shown the two men on foot
in that sense they're
quite a lot like the tv show which omits
the horses at
many opportunities
so where the the tv show is is short on
horses
but um you know but we have horses here
and that's that's good so the two of
them were fighting in the middle of the
trident
the forward of the trident and uh
it was a whole turning point where the
everything that occurs in the books was
was set up by this fight between two men
it's great to see them at this point
looking you know in the prime of their
lives and so heroic because by the time
we
jump into the narrative of of game of
thrones
robert is kind of over the hill
it makes you i mean this makes you see
why he was
you know why people thought so highly of
him to begin with
um robert was like me when i begin this
[Laughter]
my hair was dark i was skinnier it was
kiddos
i was different in 91
[Laughter]
you know it's also
rhaegar has kidnapped roberts betrothed
and and ned's sister but
it's really the culmination of a lot of
forces i mean this is a
a big personal confrontation but it's
also kind of a big
you know kind of socio-political
confrontation
um the the targaryens
king aries was crazy and
their their sort of line seemed to be
kind of decaying
well one of the one of the factors here
is of course that
300 years ago in aegon's conquest the
targaryens
conquered the seven kingdoms with
dragons but then
during the later civil war called the
dance with the dragons
the majority of those dragons were
killed
and the few that survived that war died
a relatively short time later or
else left the known lands of westeros
so by that point the targaryens were
firmly established as the kings
and had you know the the power
of tradition and legitimacy behind them
generations had come up of age with the
idea of the targaryens were the king
and
that the rules didn't apply to them i
mean that was also part of it you know
targaryens were interlopers from another
culture and they had some
um unique factors that didn't
necessarily fit into
the mainstream of the other westerosi
lords such as their
traditional incest uh you know which was
part of keeping the bloodlines
pure so that they could uh better
control the the dragon's brother
marrying sister and
and you know nephews and
aunts and and so forth and and um
all of that is detailed in the book all
of the matches and and so forth but
by the time this comes around the
targaryens
have not had dragons for a long time
and and i guess robert and some of the
other lords are starting to say you know
we don't
really have to be that afraid of these
guys anymore they can no longer
you know just fly overhead and burn down
our castles our entire cities and it's
beginning to
just this is beginning to dawn into it
that maybe the targaryens are just
people like
other people and not uh an outside alien
force with uh
with strange scaly superpowers
of course then danny well you know
[Laughter]
so that's what the books are all about